let's go next to our caller from the 805
area code who's calling today from 8:05
hello yes it sounds like you both on
speaker and at a bowling alley
can you hear me at all I am yeah I'm
sorry but I was on a lot of both correct
well you're on a boat for I'm on Clark
I'm sorry you're on a bus okay all right
yeah so can you hear me probably I can
sort of feel you yes what what's on your
minds in it
Hey so um I'm just I'm calling kind of
like a tactical question without them
and like how the Democrats should kind
of a navigate 21 20 20 I know that
recently there's kind of there's kind of
that like um I know recently destiny
made a video where he kind of faded
backs that kind of working with like run
like congressional candidate that's
English in Senate is but don't use
corporate PAC money and don't really
only their kind of uncorrupted kind of a
very privileged like it's kind of a very
privileged position to come from it's
kind of you're taking a you taking a
stance that like them that you kind of
[ __ ] you're prioritizing like a very
kind of like it asked facts like
principle of purity over like the
well-being of people who are former most
like not affected by the political
circus back okay
and I was just wondering on like do you
think that that there is value in liking
can we really justify trying to run
candidate on without corporate pack
money like uncorrupt candidate if it
results in if it results in more
Republican with like very good yes I
think I got it listen I think that the
short I haven't seen the commentary
you're mentioning but in short I think
that not accepting corporate PAC money
is a great thing and I hope it becomes
the new normal I do think that if it's
going to cost you seats then we have to
question what is it that it is going to
help us achieve if we are literally
losing to Republicans as a result of
doing it but it's just it's so crazy
where you are that I'm gonna let you go
maybe you can call back with a better
connection at some point because it's
just I hope you're not driving the bus I
hope you're just on the bus because it
sounds like it is really really chaotic
there let me go to our caller from the
562 area code who's calling today from 5
6 - that's you yen what's going on with
your phone I don't know it sounds like
you're talking through a pillow that's
really weird what better right now it's
marginally better yeah what's your
what's your question okay okay so my
question here is okay is this the same
person or did you hand the phone to
somebody else okay now I'm hearing
myself on a I got a bailout I'm sorry it
sounds like you're listening to this on
honest we we we've got
63 people holding I I just I can't deal
with that right now I apologize